après des pluies torrentielles qui ont
provoqué un glissement de terrain nous
sommes sur l'île volcanique d'Ischia à
une trentaine de kilomètres de Naples la
boue avec elle maison et voiture rien
n'a été épargné sur son passage certains
véhicules ont fini leur parcours
partiellement en se vit sur la plage ou
carrément dans la mer le nettoyage des
rues a commencé et les secouristes ont
signalé avoir débuté les recherches pour
retrouver des gens portaient disparus
plutôt dans la journée la confusion
régnait sur le nombre de disparus le
ministre italien de l'infrastructure
ayant annoncé huit morts il a été
démenti par son collègue de l'Intérieur
qui expliquait que les conditions
météorologiques ont rendu difficile le
début des opérations sauvetage
des opérations qui se poursuivent entre
autres pour aller secourir des familles
prisonnières de leur maison dont les
accès sont bloqués par la boue les
autorités locales demandent d'ailleurs
aux habitants de l'île de rester à la
maison afin de ne pas gêner les
opérations de secours la ville de
casamitua le terme compte 8000 habitants
en hiver connus pour ces termes la ville
a été frappée par un séisme en 2017 de
nombreuses immeubles s'étaient alors
effondrés et les experts avaient à
l'époque dénoncé les constructions
illégales et de piètre qualité qui
mettent en danger les résidents lors des
astres naturels
ici Carla Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal